this is a production of Cornell
University cool okay thanks for bearing
with me so this is just a quick overview
of where we're going to be going in
about the next hour so we'll start off
talking a little bit about fellowships
and grants what they are one fellowship
and that's the G RSP so we'll start out
by talking about some of that
eligibility and the rules associated
with this and then we'll kind of walk
you through what it's like to apply
starting off kind of big picture
contacting factoids me and kind of
developing your project and then we'll
go into some of the more nitty-gritty
details of how that works so did you
okay so just a little bit I didn't get
it and then I reapplied during my first
[Music]
I'd say maybe uncommon and a lot so
people change their research a lot after
writing the application and my name is
Lauren I also fights the NSF GFP during
a vacation to grad school and it was not
funded but it was a great way for me to
a work of my advisor and we're going to
project together and I'm still working
on that similar project through
different funding source and we're here
to answer questions
okay so scholarships fellowships grants
what's the difference so this language
kind of get
[Music]
to kind of the same types of funding
opportunities with different language
but in general I think that scholarship
is something that's just paying your
tuition to help you go to school
fellowships are something that I
generally think of as paying your salary
or like us while you're in school just
awesome and then grants might do that as
well or they might be more for research
funding so why so it's definitely
possible that applying just increases
your chances and then life with funding
is easier so when you come into a
program with your own funding I'm
teaching if more time for research and
having your own funding will mean that
you can do the research that you really
want to do and you'll be less tied to
like your supervisors grant or something
and as Lauren kind of hinted at this was
also just great going through the
application process you'll really have
to think deeply about your ideas and
what you really want to do and that's
just like an awesome thing to do and
will help you out even if you don't end
up getting you know still to hear me
like this entry's thank you I appreciate
that
[Music]
improvement improvement yeah all right
well all right so yeah in this workshop
we're going to talk specifically about
the National Science Foundation there's
about 2000 Awards per year across all of
the STEM fields the award provides three
years of stipend at about 34 grand a
year and that amount does go up over
time like to adjust for inflation and
all that good stuff and it also provides
tuitions I'm also just going to say
after that to say this before we're
gonna be sending you all of these slides
and in addition to a bunch of extra
resources so don't stress about like
writing stuff down right now if you're
welcome to take notes we'll send all of
us and so okay in addition with the GRP
there are one of these extra bonus
opportunities that you can get needs to
do government internships land with a
federal agency so those are kind of some
cool extras so with the geography one
thing to keep in mind is that it's
possible to make yourself competitive
and contention where you're one of the
top okay so this is our general timeline
overview of how the GRP works so we have
the exact dates for the 2018 award
competition so the application will we
do then for some reason to give your
reference letter writers about an extra
week then your letters will be due so
then who you submit a draft
awesome yes you'll hear back from
schools then you'll hear back from the G
RFP before decision deadlines for you
decide and so the things might change a
little bit for the G RFP but it's
generally kind of like this time line
also please like raise your hand ask
questions at any point or just shout him
out yeah yeah so I'm just gonna repeat
that question so the question was about
how does kind of applying for the grant
and they're helping your application and
yeah I think you're right that just
seeing that you're applying later trying
to make that happen it's something that
still is like to see and then also
typically when you apply you may contact
p.i that you're actually interested in
joining their lab and talk to them about
your project idea because you'll end up
proposing something that's very specific
it could be directed at a specific lab
so that's also a way of showing it
really interested in a place and that
can help okay
so fun stuff eligibility and rules so
you can apply as many friends as you
like before you start grad schools you
can apply when you're a senior an
undergrad anytime before you've started
grad school if you take a year or two
off you can keep applying during that
time and then once you're in a program
graduate students are limited to one
application
and that would be either during the
first year or the second year of
graduates and unfortunately if you don't
have US citizenship national Oakland
residents and you also become ineligible
if you've completed your grad or
professional degree by first the year of
application but there are exceptions to
this and I'm definitely not an expert
about geography eligibility so if you
have questions definitely come ask and
likely what will happen is we can put
you in touch with someone who is super
familiar with this at most schools there
is someone who will kind of be the
person who oversees all of the gr FP
recipients and they're like a really
good source of information
okay so you've submitted your
application and October then woohoo so
now what's gonna happen so I made a
collagen evolutionary biology and my
panel would probably either be ecology
or evolutionary biology so they're super
broad so you know I I studied plant
pollinator interactions but the people
who read my application could send me a
whole range of topics ecology or
evolutionary biology so those panelists
really might not be super knowledgeable
or well versed in the technicalities of
your discipline so that's something to
keep in mind as you're writing and so
the review criteria these two big pieces
that
including intellectual merit and broader
context so intellectual merit is
basically this idea that your work
should have the potential to advance
knowledge either across fields so there
should be some kind of like novel aspect
to what you're proposing that will
advance science and then broader impacts
are this idea that NSF wants the work to
have this potential to benefit society
so that could be the research itself
like if you work on something that has a
lot of applications to agriculture or
fighting diseases or things like that
but it also you can also have broader
impacts through activities that are
related to or supported by the research
so if you are involved in some kind of
scientific outreach program way too big
the top ticket money so see what I kind
of yes so the question is about you know
how exactly intellectual merit and
broader impacts are scored and yeah the
answer is definitely that you need both
so if one of them is super high and one
of them the reviewers really isn't as
great you won't just get the fellowship
because you have great continental merit
or great broader impact you need really
to have both of them be well developed
ok so here's just a little bit more
about what makes a successful
application so we've been talking about
intellectual merit and broader impacts
the panelists really like to see
creative original or transformative
concepts which just even saying that
made me nervous because oh my gosh like
how are we supposed to be doing that at
the beginning of our careers but you can
do it you just take time to really think
about what would push your field and try
to propose something that you feel like
it'd be cool to see that anything hasn't
been done before in some way they'd
really like to see well reasoned with an
organized basis for activity and a way
of assessing success so think we'll talk
about this more later but that comes
from having clear hypotheses that you
can test with your project so they
really like to see it a focus project
that is clear and it seems like you can
do it and you'll really learn something
from doing it so another thing that
matters are the qualifications of the
individual and
the organization for the activities so
it can be tricky if you're proposing to
move into an area of research you really
haven't worked in before so it helps
with this to kind of play to your
strengths like I've already worked with
this kind of system before so that would
help me do this project or the lab that
I'm joining has worked in this system
for a long time so that will help me I
don't do this project and then kind of
building off of that they're also
looking for you know do you have
adequate resources and support at an
institution or through collaboration so
again like does it make sense that you
can do the project based on who else
you're working with and what yeah so the
question is kind of about like who your
collaborators can be and yeah there was
not necessarily always working with an
academic institution can that kind of
work towards this and I think yes it can
I will say that yes so being affiliated
with an institution is sort of essential
on some level because you are applying
to go to grad school and getting a PhD
you know typically it involves being
affiliated with the university all other
arcs and programs will be joining with
like conservation organisations and
things like that so I think yeah you
want to stress that you're going to be
in a certain lab or in a certain
graduate program but then if you know
that you have those connections to say
agencies or conservation groups or
something like that already that can be
really great
I just wouldn't rely solely on
non-academic collaborations or
connections so that's a great question
so the question is how specific should
your connection be to a specific lands
produced specific so you will write this
proposal as if you have decided and you
are going to work with a specific
professor out of specific place and if
you don't end up doing that that's fine
but you just kind of pretend in some
ways that that's what you're going to do
so it's also it also could be the case
that as you're applying you say oh I can
work with this person at this place to
do this project
and you may even be sharing that
application with other pies we're not
the person that you named but that's
okay you just kind of want that
placeholder in - yeah show that you have
something really specific in mind when I
was applying every touch professor that
I wanted to work with this is kind of my
interest area do you have to clean this
or can we do something together like I
wrote up and it was very much yep so the
question is obviously I'm telling you to
be specific and pick one person one
tailoring your application to what
happens if that's not where you go or
you don't get in there or something
that's totally fine
so no one holds you to what you rank in
here it's fine and we'll get into this a
little bit more but part of the
geography is kind of just seeing how
well a little can develop a project and
write about it and it's like how the
fundament that panelists are that you
can do science on this level as an
early-stage grad student
so yeah whether or not you actually
pursue that project it really doesn't
matter one way or the other
yes so the question is about how early
we start contacting people and I'm gonna
pull up on answering that because we are
gonna get to that in a minute so any
other questions about this stuff like a
very big picture just make it totally
Fanta and it's the funding follows you
anywhere yes like it's time to you not
to institution yes so holistic review
okay this line is going to be a disaster
but I'll walk you through it so this is
all about basically given this timeline
that we've already outlined for the G
RFP
yeah you're gonna want to start coming
up with your ideas for projects in the
summer and early fall and I think that
really getting into the writing
contacting professors is something that
you want to start kind of with for this
year starts and September so like
mid-august I think it's often a really
great time and if you do it super early
it's possible that people are doing
field work or they're just kind of not
on email fully and you might get lost if
you do it too late people are already
super busy with the semester so once
you've started thinking about your ideas
you want to contact potential key eyes
with a written project idea and then let
them know or as you would talk back and
forth more than later you're going to
want to follow up with a full draft
yep so the question is would even the
chance question about the G RFP upgrade
in your first full female professor and
I think that's totally fine yeah I think
it's great to say hey you know this is
who I am and what I'm hoping to do you
know you're attaching your CV to that
and then you can also say and then
working on a G RFP application like is
that something that I can talk to you
more about you just have go from there
so as you're starting this process we
want to highlight the resources that
you're going to have so you have
professors that you can talk to you both
may be our current professors if you're
still in school or the professors that
you have when you're an undergrad you
can talk to you with graduate students
so we are all here to help either this
fall or in the future I
and also talk to the Brad students at
some of the institutions that are going
to you or that you're applying to people
interested in hey did you apply for the
G RFP would you maybe be willing to look
at my materials and then there's lots of
other sources for writing support so for
those of you who are still in school I
know a lot of schools like writing
centers that you can go to and bring you
know drafts of your work and those can
be great for this so yeah at the bottom
of this slide it's okay to ask someone
to read the work so I can't stress don't
feel like you have to work on this in a
vacuum by ourselves you should get as
many people as you can to read your work
and give you feedback it's still going
to end up being your work but at the end
of the day but putting yourself out
there to get feedback is really good
do you have any other questions up to
that point it's a lot of information
alright then we'll keep rolling so we're
talk about some of the details of the
proposal itself so in this you need to
have two statements one as a research
statement and this is two pages which
it's not a lot of space to say
everything you do say about a research
project and then a personal statement
any of three pages for that range of
relevant forms and any of your future
goals and these statements we've
presented to your viewers in the same
packet and they should be kind of
related so bring them seriously you love
dolphins don't talk about microbes in
your personal statement like dolphins in
your research statement have some
cohesive flow between them and we're
talking about a few more examples of
those yes
[Music]
so the question was how much is research
you've already done way into whether or
not you'll you're accepted being
accepted for this fellowship I think it
certainly helps to have say that you
have this experience I think for a
couple of reasons
so first you'll be able to talk about it
a little bit more comfortable way so you
kind of notes in the language and notes
in the techniques already you'll be
learning something new to write this
proposal and I think also you'll be able
to demonstrate that you're also capable
of doing this proposal it might just
sound a lot more feasible to the
reviewers if that is what you're
proposing and you can talk about that
also in your personal statement to you
so they'll be of something that you've
done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the question is on single states are
double-spaced these are single spaced
and we're going to go over some of the
little formatting later all right
any more questions all right oh and
speaking of the personal statement the
next workshop we're reviewing personal
statements so there'll be some great
time soon
all right the other part of your
application are three recommendation
letters and they shouldn't be some
people who know your motivations and
here you can trust to write a really
excellent it's really helpful thing come
from different points or different
aspects of your life and undergrads so
for instance maybe a professor you've
worked for or someone who's your advisor
or maybe someone who is in a non
research related job that you're in so
for instance my reference letters for
two professors and I worked in a
tutoring center so is the director of
the two books that Arthur and me also on
make sure they can all speak to your
ability to do graduate research and so
some of this is helping them do that so
writing letters for quite a few students
do you want to share them your CV
sheriff in the statements you're sending
to the NSF and also share any review
criteria or ease you want them to
highlight and make it really easy for
them to write an excellent letter this
is what the NSF wants to hear here's
some things that I've done please put
this into a nice letter it's totally
fine to ask for that and give them that
guidance yeah yeah so the comment was
I'm writing like a skeleton letter for
your advisor I think yeah that's a good
advice I think depending on your
relationship with your advisor may be
like having sentences for them might
it's too far but I would certainly at
least like bullet points like here's the
criteria here's my cpu and if you could
please make sure you talk about this
experience that is I don't know I mean
stepping on their toes or maybe making
them feel a little bit too much but
again it depends on you know how you
know them all right so you've been
talking a lot about this and we're gonna
send you about five ones that were
successful application and so there's
four of them that are from Phoebe and
those are the first four titles and to
them are successful ones too so you can
yeah and just one thing to keep in mind
while reading these these were all from
different years and some other rules
might have changed if you see some
anisette website this is do this and you
see something else in this statement
although it's on the NSF website don't
look to the aside as an example that you
must follow but they're all really great
because they deal with presenting
intellectual merit and broader impacts
of different ways some people have in
the research and personal statement you
know a bold title is in Auto Maris and a
bold title of broader impacts others are
more integrated throughout you can see a
bunch of different examples of how
people kind of tackle this and yeah
they're really great so read through
also we mentioned earlier connecting the
research statement to the personal
statement you'll see on some of the of
how people have done that and we're
going to talk about that a little bit
more too
[Music]
[Music]
the questions will receive personal
statements - and the answer is yes so we
have research and personal statements
some of them some grad students were
only willing to share ones you might
have one that it's not a complete
application but there are at least four
more complete applications that will
give you so all right and then the
formatting rules you have to follow them
there's no you don't form any grants for
this application others if the rules are
followed they will not review your
application so please take them
seriously and don't be like 11.75 it's
gonna fit like don't hire me paper of
one-inch margin and you can use Times
New Roman or a last type of font but you
can use 10-point font for references and
for your legends and again it's single
spaced and it's two pages maximum and
that's including everything you want to
put in for the research statement it's
two pages next month and that includes
everything you want to put it in that
research statement for the question was
is that one experimenters and multiple
experiments in one so in general it's
one experiment of a couple hypotheses or
objectives so for instance in one of and
it's some of these statements just the
it's like no work of mycorrhizae fungi
and it's characterizing different
metabolites or something about the
genetic control of micro eyes little
attachment to plan
two or three yeah how much research -
[Music]
all right so uniform anything make sure
you take full advantage of the space
most people will fill up the whole two
pages for the research statement and the
full three pages for the personal
statements and then also don't forget
that you can use things like bold or
italic so maybe some people will put
their main hypotheses their objectives
in full just to draw the reader's
attention so this is the main idea of
this paragraph and the main idea the
next paragraph and then there's a
certain citation style it's the citation
style use and nature or science papers
and it's how many of you have used a
citation manager before let's I did in
an undergrad zone very happy to see that
so if you are a citation manager it's
three different software's like there's
some free ones like mentally or endnotes
I think are the two big ones and what it
is is you can upload
various papers you've read to this
manager and then through Microsoft Word
or whatever WordPress that you're using
you can insert citations through there
and then it'll build a references list
for you in the citation that you talk to
and we're not going to talk about how to
use this here but your library resource
that your undergrad certainly know how
to use those in a definite set you up
and for the future to make sure you
don't make a mistake in this citation
style and then you can't have figures or
images and that's proposal and if you
have a graph or something that can save
you four sentences and what you try to
explain it's really excellent and don't
forget these panelists are reading so
many movies that you can have a nice
figure graph that's going to make your
stand out a little bit too in all the
words they're reading yeah totally so
the question what's a good-sized stare
figure and I think pretty small so if
you can have something that you can fit
into hi like maybe 1/2 inch by 1/2 do
something that fits small and if you
know you can't make it work then you try
it out hmm yeah it's true so the
question is if it's really gonna save
you word since you need to have a
caption - so the captions can be a
10-point font so I could save you a
little bit of space and often you don't
need to necessarily repeat everything
that's in the graph you can you know if
you're showing I graph of like plant
growth - like nitrogen you can say
something brought about the trend versus
like specifically like these four plants
had higher growth her nitrogen input
than these plants see and say something
they were important talking the insane I
like there's a differential plant growth
based on nitrogen accumulation figure
one and that's a shorter sentence and I
think that if you go like a Writing
Center to of some of this they will also
be able to help make the most of your
using and I don't know about like ax
these legends of those can go below ten
points
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so for the writing aspect
again you really do need to be specific
so stating your hypotheses and
objectives really clearly and how you
will test them is really important in a
research statement there's it has to
happen and Aurora and hex are also
important so Andy wants to relate those
both in your personal statement and your
research statement by excelling a link
through those they have a quick example
so for instance some of the proposals
that will share with you at the end of
the research statement or maybe some
other students by involving students in
summer research through fellowship on
this aspect of the project so you're
tying in different tutoring and want to
bring that into your a research
statement that's how you would do that
and again you'll see some examples of
those later alright and there's a lot of
resources to help you out with this so
like he said we're sharing these finds
of you are sharing a bunch of a bunch of
applications with you there's also a lot
of databases though that we're not
Michigan the NSF website has all of the
guidelines that we've kind of talked
through in more there's these important
who we've mentioned there's the couple
there's a Twitter link - and don't
forget to ask your pis other grad since
you've worked with the applied yeah and
we're sharing
[Applause]
yes the question is how much longer will
the NSF have er the'res if we both hope
a long time I don't know when the like
funding cycle is but they're definitely
heavy it this year yep so the 2018
competition I would say is almost
certainly going to happen for three
years so 2019 is a little bit more
unknown but I'd say 2018 is pretty
likely I really hope that this program
will continue I think it's been really
successful and it's hard to imagine that
cutting it it's in a different it's
staffed in a different way from another
program that they did
- effects graduate students so because
of that I'm kind of hopeful that this
will stick around but I guess with that
being said it's a great reason to apply
this coming year like if you think that
interested you know don't we so the
question is if the program were to be
terminated in the future would you still
three years of funding and that is a
scary hypothetical that I don't know for
sure but I imagine that you would still
get the funding because the program that
the NSF recently cancelled that was
another program for graduate students is
called the doctoral dissertation
Improvement Act and I know that people
who got those before it's canceled
they're still getting funding so even if
they hadn't spent it all canceled faster
available and so I think so the
questions about a database for other
grants you can apply to before you're in
grad school and I can't say that I know
for sure but I think that there are
resources out there and we will ask
around and try to find those for you
also I know my department maintains a
list of grants and fellowships but the
vast majority of it was for students who
are already in a program so I think in
the geography at this point is a little
bit special in this respect how you can
apply for as if incoming student the EPA
needs to have a similar fellowship that
program has been discontinued I'm not
sure about like do any Department of
Energy if they have anything like this
I don't know about the DOI now for the
USDA it's all after wandering in a
program there aren't any create programs
through the USDA but that's a great
question what if your research is more
research basic research where the goals
are really generating new knowledge
versus like applied research where
you're solving a problem like disease or
something broader impacts really focus
and in addition to me that was talking
about doing how I returned to these the
high school in being involved in a
couple of different programs so yeah I
think you better
this from statements but you can really
knock things that lack spirit feel world
kind of music other activities that we
do and I think jackets I worked in a
very applied field and the ms.fer paid
tends to steer more towards basic
science or poses so they wanna see I had
classes that you're testing and how
you're going to test it so for a lot of
us if we did think I kinda wanna try
this on a farm and see how it works
that doesn't really even that does have
a parodic impact doesn't really cut it
as the main core of the research
proposal for the G RFP so it meets some
aspected like finding out a genetic
mechanism and then your broader impacts
you know saying that through this
genetic mechanism may be a good health
snap reading or something like a I think
for the the research card the broader
impacts that can be a more society note
ask but for the other like average
woman's that Kate was too much about
that can be a sign know that has to be a
more of a central part of your broader
impacts so they really want to know
[Music]
totally I'm building up that too
especially being talked about an average
hood activity that you've already done
and building off of that that sounds a
lot more powerful that you can do versus
if you've never done a certain average
activity before you've done to reach you
[Music]
yeah and from the other side so you have
a more ply project so they working on
Disney's r6 cucumbers if you don't have
like trial Emmys on-farm like health and
help farmers in your broader impact
statement I feel like what like you just
talked about a very applied Kaji but
it's not part of your impact statement
so yes yeah kind of like keep telling it
to how your what's our product you're
proposing and make sure it's consistent
throughout yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so that comment was reminding you
of a website you maybe heard about
yesterday pathways to science which is a
great resource and there's always going
to more specific resources out there so
talking to red students and professors
can be another way of finding those if
you don't know them well I think we're
about out of time so thanks everyone for
listening and if you come up with more
questions at any point we'll both be
around
make sure this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu